daily beast left-wing website joe
biden's dogs have told this pet psychic
a lot about their beloved master
and his future i'll just read you the
first paragraph
pet psychic beth lee krauther says that
joe biden's dogs major in champ
told her they are excited to live in the
white house they also say
their master will be a great president
champ says he needs memory foam bedding
to ease problems with his joints major
thinks he may have dental problems both
dogs say joe biden's troubles with
donald trump
are far from over but that their master
is calm and focused enough to steer
america forward
the wisdom and prophecies of this pet
psychic go on but
i i think you get the point
the same people who tell you that
christianity is crazy
ridiculous so how nuts are you to
believe
the old fables in a book written by
illiterate goat herders or what i don't
know whatever they say about the bible
the same people who tell you that's
crazy they believe this stuff
they run this stuff they do and even for
the people who
maybe they're just listening to the pet
psychic story as a kind of funny
sideshow but they don't really take it
seriously
well they might not take this seriously
but i bet they'll take
maybe their horoscope seriously i can't
tell you how many conversations i've
been in
with friends of mine many friends of
mine
all over the country who really really
believe in the horoscopes
i mean they they'll they're avowed
atheists but they believe in the
horoscopes
or friends of mine who they think
going to church is crazy but they can't
miss their yoga session
because yoga they can't explain it but
it really centers their spirit
you know it gets all of their energy in
the right order it is a liturgy for them
i mean i've had friends of mine say that
yoga is their church
and it is because yoga is a religious
liturgy whether we admit it or not
how many people do how many people take
if they say well
look i don't believe in any of that
hokie metaphysical stuff but i
eat this very special diet because this
very special diet not only helps me lose
weight but it just gets my whole
body and spirit in order together so i'm
communing more appropriately with the
world all these kind of hokey things
which are usually based on nothing all
those fad-ish diets
do you remember a few years ago when
everyone suddenly had celiac disease
somehow the rates of celiac disease
increased by seven zillion percent
and even the people who were honest and
admitted they didn't have celiac disease
they said
well i i don't have celiac disease but i
still have a gluten
allergy i still i'm i still have gluten
sensitivity
and their their evidence for this was
that when they stopped stuffing their
face with bagels every day they felt
better
they said i must have a medical
condition no i think
i think just stuffing your face with
bagels is not going to make you feel
great
i say this is a man who regularly stuffs
his face with bagels
that's i'm a new yorker this is the sort
of thing that we do
all of these kind of hokey theories
these hokey ideas the crystals
i mean i lived in los angeles everyone
talks about these
the effects of crystals and incense and
all this kind of nonsense
that is superstitious that is part of a
religious liturgy
and it is much crazier than anything you
will find
in true religion the irony here is that
religious people are the least
superstitious people i know
because they are grounding their beliefs
about the metaphysical world
in rigorous thought rigorous study saint
thomas aquinas was not a
superstitious man he was one of the
greatest logicians we've ever had in our
civilization
isn't i you often hear if you don't
stand for something you will fall for
anything
there's an irony that the it is the
irreligious who are the most
superstitious people
did you miss out on our amazing black
friday deal well
we have a cure for your fomo that's
right today only
join us as a daily wire member for 50
off with code dw50 over at dailywire.com
subscribe since last year's deal we've
added so many more features and products
to our membership program
and we're extremely excited about it
we've added more exclusive readers past
content our insider and above members
can now stream our content on apple tv
and roku which is huge
because we're adding more content every
day such as bringing you the michael
knowles show
five days a week starting friday
december 4th and
if you're an all-access member you get
to join all access live
our exclusive daily live streams with me
or one of the other hosts where we can
talk to you directly about just about
anything
and more importantly where we can steal
your ideas and use them on the shows
we offered this incredible deal last
year but we may not be able to offer it
again next year
so be sure to become a member today
using coupon code dw50
over at dailywire.com subscribe
[Music]
you